getting to space is hard right now it's
like going up a mountain on a unicycle
with a backpack full of explosives
incredibly slow you can't transport a
lot of stuff and you might die
a rocket needs to reach a velocity of
about 40 000 kilometers an hour to
escape from earth
to get to that speed rockets are mostly
containers for fuel with a tiny tip of
payload
this is bad if you want to go to other
planets because you need a lot of heavy
stuff if you want to survive and maybe
even come back
so is there a way to get to space with
less fuel and more payload
[Music]
[Music]
a nice thing that solved most of our
transport problems on earth is what you
call infrastructure
whether it's roads for cars ports for
ships or rails for trains we've made it
easier to get to places
we can apply the same solution to space
travel
space infrastructure will make getting
into orbit and out to the moon mars and
beyond easier and cheaper great but what
exactly is space infrastructure
unlike an earth space elevator which is
currently science fiction there is a
simple yet promising technology that
does not require new science magic
materials or huge investments and that
has been tested successfully in orbit
already
a cable and a weight known as a tether
the concept is so simple it's surprising
what if we put tethers hundreds or
thousands of kilometers long into space
and had spacecraft use them as ladders
to climb to higher altitudes and gain
speed
this concept is known as the skyhook
it works even better if we make it spin
a counterweight holds a long cable in
place while it rotates around a circle a
rotating tether slows down its tip
relative to the ground at the bottom and
speeds it up at the top like a catapult
this means that you can transfer energy
from the tether and get a massive boost
when released more or less for free
equal to twice the tethers rotation
velocity
specialized fibers already exist that
can survive the extraordinary stresses a
skyhook would be faced with
to protect against cuts and collisions
from debris and meteorites we can thread
our tether into a web of redundant
fibers
since our skyhook would pass over the
same spot many times a day this would
allow small reusable shuttles to catch
up with it of course it's not that easy
at its lowest point the tethers tip is
dashing through the atmosphere at around
12 000 kilometers per hour because of
earth's atmosphere we can't lower the
sky hook too much or it will get too hot
from air friction so it will dip to a
height of 80 to 150 kilometers and no
lower
to match this we'll need specialized
spacecraft that can get to the tether
while this isn't exactly easy it's still
much cheaper than getting a big tin can
filled with rocket fuel to go 40 000
kilometers an hour
catching the tip will be a challenge too
there's only a short time window of 60
to 90 seconds to find a tiny thing in
the sky moving at mark 12.
to make this easier the tip could have a
sort of fishing line a kilometer long
with a navigation drone that helps the
spacecraft connect
another challenge is keeping our sky
hook in orbit as more and more ships
latch onto it and pull themselves up
they use up the momentum that keeps it
in place
if we don't do anything it will slow
down and crash into the atmosphere
and here we can cheat the universe a bit
the sky hook is a battery of orbital
energy it's possible to balance the
payloads coming in and being sent off
arriving ships bringing humans and
materials home to earth add energy to
the tether which it can give to other
ships departing into space
this way the tether doesn't lose any
energy the more we use it the cheaper it
gets
if we're still losing energy with each
boost we can recover it with small
electric or chemical engines that
regularly correct the tether's position
a set of tethers one around earth and
one around mars could make trips between
the planets fast straightforward and low
cost compared to rockets
the earth tether would sit in low earth
orbit to grab people and payloads and
fling them off to mars
the mars tether catches them and slows
them down for a landing on the surface
in the opposite direction the tether
could pick up a vehicle traveling
through mars's thin atmosphere at only
about one thousand kilometers an hour
not much faster than our airliners on
earth and fling it back to earth to be
caught and lowered down
the tethers could shorten trips between
both planets from nine months down to
five or even three and reduce the scale
of the rockets required by between 84
and 96 percent
even better people may be able to travel
in relative luxury as we could afford to
invest in passenger comfort tether
travel would be first-class seats to
mars
together tethers around earth and mars
could provide the rapid and efficient
transportation backbone that would make
space travel affordable
but let's go further
starting from low mars orbit a tether
could boost ships to the asteroid belt
the first craft sent to a new asteroid
would need rockets to slow down at its
destination
subsequent arrivals might find a tether
waiting to catch them and send them back
for free
getting to asteroids cheaply is a major
factor in opening up the resources of
the solar system
precious metals and valuable minerals
could be delivered to mars just weeks
after they were cut out of their
asteroid
they would be the perfect building
blocks for our interplanetary
civilization
but why stop here
mars moons are very convenient no other
moons in the solar system orbit that
close to their planet
phobos is so heavy that we don't need to
worry about slowing it down making it
the perfect attachment point for super
tethers just under 6000 kilometers long
the lower tip would fly just over the
surface of mars and be very easy to
catch
the upper tip can fling ships all the
way to jupiter and saturn
the same super tether can also bring the
inner solar system closer
venus and mercury are a single swing
away
unlike mars they're bursting with solar
energy and are rich in minerals
in the long term nothing is stopping
humanity from constructing a zero
propellant transport network for the
terrestrial planets centered on the
martian moons
tethers are a comparably cheap and
sustainable solution to making space
travel affordable and the rest of the
solar system accessible for exploitation
and exploration
considering that we have the technology
to build them today there's really no
good excuse to wait any longer
parts of the solar system are far away
but they could be very close
speaking of stuff that's hard to reach
but doesn't have to be
knowledge
our friends from brilliant can hook you
up to a universe full of explosive ideas
and fun courses
brilliant is a website that helps you
tackle science in a practical way with
interactive problem-solving courses and
daily problems in maths logic and
engineering
each problem gives you all the tools you
need to crack complex topics all by
yourself it's learning by doing but with
your brain instead of your hands
use your curiosity to get to the bottom
of puzzles and courses about things like
classical mechanics astronomy
gravitational physics and much more
if you click the link in the description
or visit brilliant.org nutshell you can
sign up for free and learn more things
than you can imagine and there's an
extra perk for courts consult viewers
the first 688 people to use the link get
20 off their annual membership which
lets you view all the daily problems in
the archives and unlock every course
brilliant helps you end your day a
little smarter
you might get hooked on the experience
[Music]